celui-ci gauche j'espère que vous allez
bien on est parti pour un nouveau
décryptage de programme d'un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle et aujourd'hui
on va donc s'intéresser à des mesures
majeures proposée par valérie pécresse
la candidate du parti de droite les
républicains au passage et je vais le
dire dans chaque vidéo de cette série
évidemment je vais pas vous présenter
tout le programme de valérie pécresse
l'idée c'est donc de vous donner un bon
aperçu est en tout cas pour ne pas
louper les décryptages des programmes
des autres candidats ainsi que les
interviews de tous les candidats à
l'élection présidentielle est bien pensé
à vous abonner simplement à 7 things you
tube merci beaucoup en tout cas pour
votre confiance et d'un jour dont la
couverture de cette élection
comme d'habitude commençons par une
petite présentation qui est valérie
pécresse et bien elle a 54 ans elle est
originaire de neuilly sur seine en
région parisienne elle a fait ses études
à l'école de commerce hec puis à l'ena
l'école donc qui forme les hauts
fonctionnaires en france école dont sont
issus notamment françois hollande ou
encore jamais nié le maquereau valérie
pécresse s'est engagée très tôt en
politique elle a occupé beaucoup de
postes à responsabilité elle a été
conseillère sous jacques chirac
ensuite député en 2007 puis elle a été
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche en 2007 quand nicolas
sarkozy était président avant de devenir
ministre du budget et depuis fin 2015
elle est la présidente de la région ile
de france c'est donc sa première
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
sa candidature fait d'ailleurs suite à
sa victoire lors de la primaire de son
parti de droite les républicains et
d'ailleurs c'est la première fois que
les républicains vont présenter une
femme à l'élection présidentielle alors
que va-t-elle mettre en place si elle
est élue présidente on va donc le voir
en dix mesures première mesure
commençons par ça comme françois fillon
qui était donc le candidat du parti
républicain en 2017 valérie pécresse
veut réduire les dépenses de l'état
puisqu'elle considère que la dette qui
s'accumule est trop importante pour ça
elle propose concrètement de supprimer
deux cent mille postes de fonctionnaires
donc des personnes employées par l'état
mais en parallèle à ces suppressions de
postes elle veut tout de même recruté 50
mille nouveaux fonctionnaires pour je
cite protéger soigner éduqué avec
notamment 25 mille personnes qu'elle
recruterait dans le secteur de la santé
deuxième mesure valérie pécresse
souhaite une augmentation des salaires
et elle dit que c'est je cite sa mesure
phare alors sa position a quand même
évolué depuis le début de la campagne au
départ elle voulait augmenter de 10%
tous les salaires les plus bas
aujourd'hui elle ne parle pas de 10%
mais plutôt d'une augmentation de 3 %
des salaires nets d'ici 2023 et pour
tous les salariés je vous la fait courte
mais cette hausse de salaire serait
permise par une prise en charge par
l'état d'une partie des cotisations
sociales et cette augmentation ça
concerne les gens qui travaillent dans
des entreprises privées sachant que pour
ceux qui travaillent dans le public
comme les enseignants ou encore les
postes de personnels soignants elle a
promis là aussi des augmentations mais
qui seront négociés secteur par secteur
concrètement pour quelqu'un payé au smic
cette hausse de 3% du salaire net en
2022 reviendrait à passer de 1200 sont 9
euros net par mois à 1307 hornets
étaient en hausse du smic serait donc
moins importante que celle voulue par
pas mal de candidats à gauche pour 2022
jean luc mélenchon par exemple veut que
le smic soit portée à 1400 euros net par
mois mais il faut noter que la mesure de
valérie pécresse ne s'appliquerait pas
juste au smic mais à tous les salaires
dans le secteur privé étant donné que ça
consiste à supprimer une charge qui est
aujourd'hui prélevées sur le salaire
brut troisième chose dans le programme
de valérie pécresse elle veut
globalement que les français travaillent
davantage et si elle est élue présidente
elle mettra fin à la règle des 35 heures
de travail par semaine aujourd'hui c'est
la base pour toutes les entreprises
depuis 2002 en france et à la place de
ça et bien elle veut que le plan de
travail soient négociés en interne dans
chaque entreprise met donc avec une base
qui ne serait plus à 35 heures mais à 39
heures par semaine l'entreprise pourrait
donc théoriquement rester aux 35 heures
après un accord en interne au sein de
l'entreprise mais ce ne serait plus la
règle générale quatrième mesure
désormais qui vise là aussi d'ailleurs à
augmenter le temps de travail valérie
pécresse veut augmenter l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite progressivement
jusqu'à 60 cents en 2030 alors
qu'aujourd'hui l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite est de 62 ans est donc ça
impliquerait de relancer dès son arrivée
au pouvoir une réforme des retraites
cinquième mesure qui s'adresse aux
jeunes de moins de 26 ans qui ne sont ni
étudiant ni employé valérie pécresse
veut qu'ils puissent avoir accès à ce
qu'elle appelle un revenu jeune actif en
fait c'est un dispositif qu'elle a déjà
lancé dans la région ile de france ça
consiste en gros à leur fournir un
revenu de 5 cents à 670 euros par mois à
condition que en échange ils suivent une
formation pour se former à un métier qui
recrute et cette formation serait
gratuite c'est donc un peu le même
principe que le contrat d'engagement qui
a été mise en place par emmanuel macron
à partir du mois de mars mais en
l'occurrence avec un revenu un peu plus
important puisque son revenu jeune actif
peut aller jusqu'à 6 ans 110 euros par
mois contre 500 euros max par mois pour
le contrat d'engagement dernier le
maquereau 16e mesure désormais on a fait
plus de la moitié vallée pécresse veut
ralentir l'immigration en france pour
cela elle souhaite mettre en place des
quotas d'accueil pour les immigrés et
donc pour faire très simple un fixe et
un nombre maximum d'immigrés par an un
nombre qui serait voté chaque année
directement par le parlement il a lui
aussi mettre fin au droit du sol
automatique le droit du sol c'est donc
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui les enfants
de parents étrangers qui naissent sur le
sol français ont quasiment
automatiquement aujourd'hui la
nationalité française à leurs 18 ans
c'est telle mesure c'est un volet
important concernant la sécurité valérie
pécresse veut renforcer les moyens de la
police et de la justice concrètement ça
veut dire notamment investir 5 milliards
d'euros pour l'équipement des policiers
armés aussi les policiers municipaux ou
encore construire vingt mille nouvelles
places de prison valley pécresse a aussi
promis une peine automatique d'un an de
prison ferme pour ceux qui s'en
prendraient physiquement aux forces de
l'ordre sachant que pour qu'une telle
mesure puisse être appliqué il faudrait
a priori une modification de la
constitution
l'utile mesure maintenant qui concerne
l'énergie c'est le sujet qui revient
dans chaque programme la question du
nucléaire valérie pécresse veut que la
france continue de miser sur le
nucléaire pour sa production d'énergie
pour ça elle souhaite que les centrales
nucléaires existantes soient modernisées
pour qu'elle puisse être utilisé pendant
plus longtemps mais elle s'est aussi
investir dans de nouvelles centrales le
nucléaire est en effet selon elle la
solution pour en finir avec le pétrole
ou encore le gaz sur l'écologie
d'ailleurs valérie pécresse parle
souvent de s'opposer à ce qu'elle
appelle une écologie punitive donc une
écologie avec des taxes et des amendes
dans son programme elle dit notamment
vouloir développer des modes de
transport en commun plus propres par
exemple en développant les métro et les
bus électriques ou encore interdire à
partir de 2035 les ventes de voitures
neuves qui fonctionne à l'essence et au
diesel une mesure qui en soi est déjà
porté aujourd'hui par la commission
européenne à l'échelle donc de tous les
pays de l'union européenne
mais j'aime mesure désormais très
concrète on va parler d'éducation et
d'ailleurs je vous en avais parlé sur
mon compte twitter qu'il ya quelques
mois la candidate du parti les
républicains veut qu'il y ait deux
heures de français en plus par semaine
et une heures de maths en plus par
semaine à l'école primaire et elle veut
aussi créer un examen avant l'entrée en
classe de sixième se souvenant qu'un
examen que passerait tous les élèves à
la fin du cm2 alors selon elle le but
n'est pas d'empêcher des élèves qui
étaient en cm2 d'entrée en sixième mais
ce serait surtout de pouvoir et bien
repérer les élèves les plus en
difficulté voire donc à les rassembler
ensuite dans des classes de remise à
niveau en 6ème enfin 10e mesure qui
concerne la crise sanitaire si valérie
pécresse est élue présidente et que de
nouveau pic de l'épidémie de couronnes
un virus apparaissent elle affirme
qu'elle n'hésitera pas à ordonner un
confinement des personnes non vaccinées
et au moment où je tourne cette vidéo
elle est également favorable au pass
vaccinale qui est mis en place donc par
le gouvernement aujourd'hui alors on
termine comme d'habitude avec quelques
mesures que je vous donne rapidement
c'est comme le en grève de nos actu du
jour sauf que là c'est pour un programme
parmi les autres mesures qu on pourrait
citer valérie pécresse souhaite que la
france ait une relation diplomatique
plus forte avec les états unis qu'elle
ne l'a aujourd'hui elle souhaite qu'une
personne puisse avoir jusqu'à 200 milles
euros d'héritage sans payer d'impôts
alors que s'est fixé à 100 mille euros
aujourd'hui il souhaite charger un
comité de réalisation et une grande
simplification du fonctionnement de
l'administration française elle souhaite
aussi abaisser la majorité pénale à 16
ans la majorité pénale c'est donc l'âge
auquel une personne est jugé avec la
même sévérité que les adultes autre
élément qu'on peut noter elle souhaite
qu'un prélèvement soit fait directement
sur le salaire d'une personne qui ne
paye pas une amende ou encore et bien
parmi les mesures contre le site et une
prime de 900 euros par an quand on a un
premier enfant 900 euros par an jusqu'au
18 ans de l'enfant dans un objectif donc
d'encourager et de relancer la natalité
dernière mesure valérie pécresse veut
créer ce qu'elle appelle une banque des
jeunes pour les aider à financer leurs
études ou encore créer leur entreprise
avec sept banques les jeunes auraient à
rembourser ses prêts que s'ils
atteignent un certain niveau de salaire
autrement eh bien c'est l'état qui les
rembourserait à leur place voilà donc
pour cet aperçu du programme de valérie
pécresse le lien de son programme et
comme d'habitude en descriptions je me
voulaient le voir en intégralité et
évidemment je le disais en début de
vidéo n'hésitez pas à vous abonner si
elle ne sait pas encore le cas cette
chaîne youtube pour ne pas louper et
bien les autres décryptage qui vont
sortir dans les prochains jours de tous
les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle ainsi évidemment que les
interviews des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
point de vous prouver à vos proches et
on se dit du coup a très vite